the exit polls don't make good reading
Kleber how you feeling at the moment
well the exit polls are very striking
they're completely at odds with all of
the opinion polls we've had for the last
six weeks and indeed last night and then
today so until we actually get some
results we're not going to know I think
so far all we know is in sundered labor
is increasing its majorities and of
course I hope that's going to be the
story for the whole night we'll have to
wait and see I think you can say is even
if this exit poll which is a real
outlier is right that means the
conservative and Liberal Democrat
majority for the Coalition has gone from
73 down to zero in this in this election
David Cameron would be clinging on
trying to make a majority work and only
doing so by reaching out to the
unionists but that would be because of
the Lib Dem fall not because of the
conservative fall and equally could go
the other way and say goodness me what
might happen in Scotland
look look look clearly if the exit poll
is is right it's a terrible result for
labour in Scotland I really hope it's
going to be wrong because we've got some
excellent MP some close colleague
friends of mine and I want to see them
come back tonight but of course we've
had no results yet the thing is if the
exit poll is either drawn by ten seats
if in those very close labour Tory
fights we take ten more suddenly David
Cameron as Prime Minister is not going
to be able to put a majority together in
the House of Commons and get a Queen's
speech through and then it would fall to
Ed Miliband to put together a Queen's
speech and put that to the House of
Commons so even if the exit poll is
right it's on a knife edge I'm not sure
this is right because it rather jars
with all the experience we've had over
the course of today and I think the term
this election is still wide open the
results will tell the story so far we've
not even got the ballot boxes here in
these there's rather a lot of counting
to do for we know what's going on there
is but isn't the bottom line that if it
pans out like it appears to be that you
have the wrong man at the top it falls
to him to clear up the mess and it is
him that hasn't led the Labour Party
forward big IFS
because so far there's no result at all
other than as I said labour doing better
in
in Sunderland what we know is that
labourers fought a really good campaign
a very very I think responsible campaign
we've not been promising to spend money
we've not got we've not followed David
Cameron into the sort of a trend to take
big risks with our relationship with
Europe or to set it all set England
against Scotland at the Ed Miliband has
had the best campaign of all the leaders
clearly and we're gonna have to wait and
see what the result is because so far
there aren't any we've got an exit poll
which even it's right puts David
Cameron's majority right on a knife edge
and I think many people are thinking
it's overstating what we all think is
going on tonight
lots of busyness here as you mentioned
there's Hilary Benn down there who's
quite safe at the moment his seat isn't
it but your constituency as you
mentioned truly the ballot boxes haven't
come in they've only counted the postal
votes 1101 of course social media is
alight now saying Ed Balls could lose
his seat what are you going to do
tomorrow all of the the votes are in the
box
they've been cast today but turnout is
high and we're going to wait and see how
it's counted what we know is that Hilary
down there has got a very very big
majority I for 8 years have been
fighting a constituency where the
majority is much tighter we fought very
hard in 2010 people predicted I might
lose and we won by a thousand today the
mood on the doorstep has been really
good very strong lots of people saying
they're worried about the health service
jobs for young people and urging labour
to win saying they're going to come and
vote so today the moods been really good
we fought a brilliant campaign in Morley
and outwards but the people have decided
their votes from the ballot box and it's
not something I decide or you decide
they decide they vote and we'll wait and
we'll wait and see in a few hours time
we'll see if you're still smiling we'll
talk to you again later I hope Marlee
thank you